what's going on people today we're
breaking down the final trailer for the
final episode of Attack on Titan and I
know what you're thinking haven't there
already been two trailers for this final
episode and yeah you'd be right to say
that there were two trailers this year
for this one episode however those were
pretty short trailers I think the last
one was only 30 seconds long this new
trailer we've got today is a minute and
30 seconds so there is a lot more
content to kind of break down and talk
about so yeah let's get into it all
right so the trailer begins with the
rumbling in full motion and was
interesting is that this city that
they're trampling here I'm like 90% sure
this is meant to be London because if
you look at this bridge and you compare
it to towerbridge in London like yeah I
think that was very intentional this has
got to be London or at least you know
the attack and Titan equivalent of
London as this continues Zeke is talking
over the trailer and we all know how
suicidal he is anyway like he remember
his plan was to eradicate or at least to
sterilize the entire Elan race so he is
not afraid of death death is something
that he almost was welcomes to an extent
and In This Moment he says that uh
perhaps one's final moments bring some
kind of relief um so he's kind of like
accepted defeat at this point um because
as we know the last time we saw Zeke he
was getting literally absorbed by the
source of all living matters so he's
pretty much done and so in the P
Dimension he's clearly talking to
someone and he's just saying you know I
guess he just accepting his Fai he's
accepting that he's going to die and
that everyone else in the world is going
to die because of eron the trailer then
flashes forward to the founder yir and
we can see her almost in the flesh in
this scene so she's standing on top of
Aaron and kind of watching the battle
unfold and in this section right here
you can see Rina fighting against the
Beast Titan or at least a version of the
Beast Titan if you've seen part three of
the final season you know that in that
episode Zeke kind of appeared it wasn't
really him it was a creation made by the
power of the Warhammer Titan and so it
was a fake Beast Titan made out of Titan
hardening that was was throwing rocks at
you know the the heroes of the story and
yeah so in this scene Rina crashes down
on Zeke and basically just turns into
dust so this at this point the Beast
Titan is turning into he's a skeleton we
then get a few shots of the cart Titan
in action ripping apart the Warhammer
Titan because as we've seen in many of
these trailers now there are various
Titans from the past that are appearing
due to eron's power to just you know
create any Titan he wants out of the
Warhammer Titan power to be specific
actually it's not really Aaron who's
creating these Titans it's more yamir
doing this to kind of defend Aaron and
yeah in this scene Peak just rips one of
them apart which shows you that the cart
Titan is actually useful cuz out of all
the nine it probably seems like the
least useful the least ready for battle
um but yeah I mean clearly with Peak at
least it does have some use now
switching over to this shot of the cabin
this part will have spoilers so just
skip to the time stamp ahead if you want
to avoid any spoilers for the final
episode but for everyone else this scene
of the cabin so this is from Aaron and
mik's uh their time they spent together
in the P Dimension because this final
episode is 19 minutes long which is
basically a movie right so I think what
they're going to do they're going to
show us a lot of extended scenes scenes
that in the manga we weren't really able
to uh be fleshed out so I'm thinking
Aaron's Aaron and mik's time in pause
I'm thinking potentially Aaron and
everyone so Aaron and John Aaron and
Annie Aaron and rer he spoke to all of
them but we only really got to see in
the manga we only saw Aaron talking to
Armen and Mikasa because the episode's
so long I'm just is my head Canon at
this point but I'm hoping and thinking
that it's so long because there are
extra scenes moving on we then get what
I think is an anime original shot of yir
smiling I don't remember ever seeing
this shot on paper it's her she's in the
real world so this must be a memory from
her childhood uh when she was working
for the for the Marans but yeah I I
don't I know this must be an anime
original scene so I'm interested to see
the context of this flashback maybe
they'll reveal like a new memory from
her past but the fact she's smiling I'm
assuming that she's just seen something
related to I mean we all know the thing
that Yuma wants is love like she has
been pining after real love since she
saw that that couple get married when
she was young so I'm guessing it's
related to that somehow as the trailer
continues we then get a shot of the
scouts Al together so Levi and his crew
and Irvin and Hani and he Levi asks an
interesting question in this moment of
the trailer he says when you all
dedicated your hearts was it to trample
on the hearts of others you know as in
was it to do something like this the
rumbling or was it to rid the world of
Titans and I think we know the answer to
that their goal as the scouts was to rid
the world of Titans that's why the
scouts was created to go outside the
walls and to you know discover new
places to eradicate the Titans and and
establish human bases outside the walls
so their goal wasn't to wipe out
Humanity like Aaron is doing and I know
you can say that they didn't know there
was Humanity outside the walls but Levi
does have a point like I doubt that most
of the scouts would support Aaron
eradicating all life on on Earth and I
know that's ironic coming from me given
that I made an entire alternate reality
where Irvin kind of does maybe support
the rumbling in a way but you know the
whole reason I made uh my alternate
reality was because it was a completely
different set of circumstances whereas
in these circumstances here I don't
think there's any way they would have
supported him anyhow following that we
then get this amazing sequence of Levi
tearing apart this ancient female Titan
and then the shot like immediately
transitions into uh Porco attacking him
as well so this was just a great action
shot just from One Titan to another um
really fastpaced stuff everything just
seems so smooth in this trailer like no
wonder they took so long to make this
final episode you know cuz it's been
quite a few months since part two but no
wonder they took so long cuz they've
been perfecting this thing it just looks
yeah it looks amazing I can't wait for
this also we then get this freaky shot
of bol's like Colossal Titan just just
appearing out of the sky and he's one of
many ancient Titans that are appearing
in this episode but it's just ironic
because obviously these guys here all
know berol so seeing his face kind of
emerge from the sky like a god almost
like this is very god-like imagery I
think yeah it's going to throw them off
guard because if I see my dead friend
appearing on the battlefield there's a
lot more emotion involved in that
compared to fighting against some random
ancient Titan also this next shot
features Rina on the ground so In This
Moment here he's no longer on top of
eron founding Titan and the way this
moment is shot there's clearly something
charging directly at him and he's kind
of like you know putting his arms out
like the Hulk ready to stop it but um
let's not get into spoilers about that
after rer there are then a couple action
shots of Connie and Mikasa just going
hard destroying Titans and we get this
moment here I love this panel here the
Warhammer Titans with their bows and
arrows it's like a literally an army of
warhammers throughout history this is
really cool following that we then get
an iconic shot I think maybe iconic for
the wrong reasons but we get Aaron
Krueger's Titan on the left we see gishy
Jager Titan on the right so the two
attack Titans behind them is berto's
Colossal Titan and then holding Armen in
the center is Tom SAA this is Zeke's
Mentor Tom SAA who was the previous
Beast Titan who had the ability to turn
into a ram so these are all Titans that
we know from some point in the story
who've who've died and they're all
holding up Armen in the center like he's
the hero of the story I think it looks
quite cool uh but there are some there
are some criticisms you could say about
this scene um especially when it came to
Aaron Krueger's ideology and what he
believed of the marlean would he support
arman's goals debatable but I guess if
the author thinks so then that's that is
what it is um but the fans you know for
us fans we can debate that kind of stuff
I personally think there's a chance
Aaron Krueger might have gone along with
what Aaron believes and I only say that
cuz his family was like brutally burnt
to death by the Marans someone who's
been through something like that he in
the same way that Aaron feels anger
against the world Aaron Krueger felt
that same anger so I don't know entirely
if he would try and stop the rumbling
but like I said if the author thinks
that then fine that's what it is the
trailer then closes out with these four
amazing shots so the first one is of
Levi dodging all of this rubble and kind
of spoiler warning ahead here but the
only moment I can think of is the moment
when Armen kind of his Titan just gets
his head caved in and there a bunch of
just Rubble coming out I'm assuming it's
from that but um yeah either way this
scene looks awesome the blue lighting
around the Flames as well it just it
just looks epic it just looks so good
like a movie and I guess this is
basically a movie though cuz 1990
minutes long for a final episode 1990
minutes used to be a movie back in the
day I swear like Shrek was like 90
minutes um so this is this is going to
be a movie level event for sure the next
amazing shot is of rer just body
slamming this Warhammer Titan which I
thought was cool and possibly the most
important one of the whole trailer we
actually see the real Aaron because up
until this point ever since he
transformed into the founding Titan
we've been seeing the head of the Titan
itself but we've never actually been
seeing Aaron inside of it so now we
actually see him and he looks depressed
here clearly as you can see you can see
that his his neck is just Bare Bones
like he's basically just ahead piloting
this massive Titan but his body hasn't
regrown at this point Titan Shifters
don't heal automatically like if they
don't have the will to to heal
themselves then they won't heal
themselves and so Aaron still being a
decapitated head in this moment even
after doing the rumbling for all these
days he's had time to transform and heal
himself and he hasn't done it so that
should tell you something lastly the
final moment is Armen transforming into
his Colossal Titan and I know I already
said this looks like a movie but this
shot especially looks like a movie like
it's just this is Peak fiction that's
what it is um but honestly guys I can't
wait one week from today the final
episode is coming out on Saturday the
4th of November and yeah after that
we're pretty much done like there's no
more Attack on Titan after this uh I
don't think is is going to you know make
a prequel series or sequel series or
anything like that so this really is the
end of this iconic series that's been
going on for over a decade you know and
and the manga ended two and a half years
ago I think maybe yeah it was around two
years ago so this episode really is the
end of of everything really so yeah I
mean it is what it is there's other
things to watch like for example jju
kaisen you know if you're a that you can
watch that and speaking of J kaisen I
wanted to give a shout out to Gallery
Panda official they gave me this awesome
print of Gojo which is like it's not
just a poster it's like it's not just a
normal poster it's kind of thick you
know and yeah Gallery Panda official
check them out they make amazing prints
and the price is pretty good as well
thank you for watching as always and
until the next one peace out